[Musique]
ces singulières en fait tout a commencé
un matin de janvier 2018 je me trimballe
allons les halles d'avignon comme tous
les jeunes retraités désoeuvrés
j'ai croisé un espace d'individus
interlope qui m'a apostrophé en me
disant j'ai pensé à toi pour le tedx dit
thierry quelqu'un qui pense à moi sur ce
territoire
c'est plutôt étonnant oui on fait un
telle x sur la conquête des territoires
j'ai pensé à toi
à propos des lettres de ton père j'avais
donc lors du festival 2016 jouer lui
donner 10 et correspondances de mon père
sous le titre palestine 1946 lettre de
mon père l'histoire est la suivante à la
fin de la guerre 39 45
georges d'une berge mais perd donc à
quitter la france
après avoir traversé la guerre en
résistant il était d'origine juive lille
décide de quitter la france avec ma mère
pour s'installer en palestine avant que
l'état d'israël ne naisse en 1948
et puis depuis la palestine il
entretient une correspondance avec son
meilleur ami d'enfance qu'il avait
connue à la maternelle à paris qui
s'appelait léon des dahlias
on a plein comme moi j'ai bien connu lit
qu il fait à la maison c'était un peu
notre oncle mon père était fils unique
et long qui délivre alico une
correspondance quasi quotidiennes
presque une chronique journalistique
sur sa tentative d'installation non
juive dans la palestine de 46 et comme
mon père décédé en 1987 j'ai retrouvé
dans ses affaires des pelures papier de
machines à écrire alors la peau l'urne
machine à écrire ne parlera pas aux
jeunes générations c'était bien avant le
copier coller c'est espèce de petit
papier très fin pour mettez derrière le
carbone pour avoir une copie de ce qu'on
écrivait et de cette somme qui était
dactylographiée très très dense
j'avais monté cette lecture environ
d'environ en fait qui m'intéresse c'est
de nous livrer aujourd'hui c'est la
singularité de cette histoire d'abord
parce que cette correspondance était
très riche
je pense que mon père avait une vision
assez lucide sur la situation d'alors et
que c'était un bonhomme un peu atypique
ce n'était pas une personne qui allait
dans les organisations n'était très
libre indépendant laïc républicain
tenait pour vous donner une petite idée
une petite synthèse du monsieur
il avait pour habitude de manger du pain
azyme vous savez ce pain très fin ça ne
présente absolument aucun intérêt c'est
la farine et de l'eau commenge à la
pâque juive ou qu'on trouve dans les
magasins de régime dans mon père prenait
cependant il le tartiner de beurre et y
rajouter les tranches de jambon dessus
et ça c'est la synthèse de george
clooney dont il a décidé d'essayer de
s'installer là bas
et moi j'ai pensé aujourd'hui me dire
tiens il ya un parcours particulier dans
un contexte historique plus que sont
réguliers alors on va pas débattre
aujourd'hui
israël palestine palestine israël c'est
pas le sujet c'est pas le propos la
complexité absolument immense et en même
temps dans parcours professionnel j'ai
eu l'occasion de m'occuper de jeanne
mineurs isolés étrangers qui viennent
aussi sur un territoire et je me suis
dit tiens pourquoi pas relié finalement
d'une certaine manière c'est j'allais
dire ces deux destins ces deux destinées
comment finalement aller vers un
territoire en essayant développer son
propre territoire intérieur alors je
vais vous donner quelques extraits de
ces lettres
si je trouve très belle mais je suis
d'une subjectivité total et père écrit à
son ami
dans une lettre datée du 2 mars 1946 il
écrit à son ami il co depuis haifa il
lui dit ceci léon mon cher locaux en
attendant j'attends bientôt un aimable
jeune homme vêtu d'un imperméable salle
très sale mais avec du linge très propre
et un regard à une voix lucide sollicite
le mois quelques minutes d'entretien la
conversation a lieu sur le pont accoudé
au bastingage et devant les lumières qui
s'allument dans la ville et le port
il fait calme et ferait tout cela est
extraordinairement détachées on ne me
pose aucune question extraordinaire non
plus mais lorsque l'entretien se termine
j'ai l'impression d'avoir été
photographié à tout jamais quelques
minutes plus tard ou me rends mon
passeport et me voilà autorisée a résidé
de manière permanente en palestine en
qualité du grand
mais il est trop tard pour les marquer
ce soir mais passeront encore une nuit à
bord lendemain matin le temps ubaye
recommence nous sommes le 28 février
dernier jour du mois des fièvres ont des
marques sur les allèges et là ça y est
je foule le sol de la terre promise à
mai et je m'arrêterai après semaine
parce qu'une allait-il pouvoir
s'installer long cette terre promise sur
cette terre promise qu'il aurait voulu
qu'elle soit tant promise et finalement
je vais vous le dire tout de suite
surtout si vous avez d'autres choses à
faire samedi après-midi en général on va
se promener dans le supermarché à midi
chariot bassa'a lamentablement foiré
c'est un peu toute la dramaturgie cette
histoire et ce genre d'affaires peut
nous arriver à tous à tout moment ne pas
arriver à se construire intérieurement
sur un territoire qu'on aurait souhaité
aborder qu'on a tellement idéalisé
tellement fantasme est tellement désiré
que finalement il en devient
inaccessible
je vous le dis je ne suis pas philosophe
rpt ne suis pas géographe
je ne suis pas historien
je dirais plutôt que je suis un passeur
sachant utiliser le terme passeur à
propos des heurts isolés étrangers n'est
pas très convenable je conçois
parfaitement plutôt transmetteur
d'expérience de mots ni des comme mon
père qui s'est certainement planter
parce que c'était pas un compère en
conquérante territoire c'était plutôt sa
conquête à lui les mots et puis les
idées il avait un point de vue très
lucide sur la situation de la palestine
d'alors il écrit à son ami lui tue c'est
la question principale ici c'est celle
du logement et du travail et sont sains
variante sera possible et plus de
soixante dix ans après ça nous fait
encore et cours et la judaïser tu sais
moi l'ico j'ai un programme pour la
palestine
mon programme comprendrait un code civil
pour tous sans distinction de races
religions ou communautés tout au moins
code civil minimum la liberté
d'immigration et tu verras qu'il y
viendra pas juif de plus l'instruction
publique en arabe et en hébreu pour tous
sans distinction
maintenant j'aime il ya quelque chose je
vais vous demander d'accrocher un peu
mou ceinture parce que le propos est un
peu plus ardue c'était son point de vue
je ne m'engage pas dans ce point de vue
forcément mais je vous le livre tel quel
puisque c'était sa vision du territoire
dgt alors il écrit à son ami où il y un
état juif est impossible par manque de
maturité les juifs de même un état arabe
ce sera un foutoir une face et comme il
ne manquait pas d'humour et que c'était
un peu le roi de la pirouette il ajoute
le meilleur gouvernement serait
peut-être une délégation du vatican
fonctionnant en latin et en france on en
est arrivé là
à ce point là où finalement mon père
n'était absolument pas à rimmel en son
for intérieur j'ai vu j'en ai souvent
reparlé avec lui
le designer en inquiète pas c'est la
tempête sous un crâne
il répétait c'est la tempête sous un
crâne je pense que sa tentative
d'installation n'a pas fonctionné parce
que son arrimage intérieur était pas
suffisamment fort il avait un bon kit
est un territoire en ruine la france à
la fin de la guerre pour espérer quelque
chose dans un endroit et ça n'a pu
aboutir
et je trouve cette histoire assez
singulière dans les moments qu'on
traverse maintenant dans les moments de
fragmentation de la société dans les
moments de repli sur soi et puis dans
ces moments on est vrai qu'en permanence
qui sont ces moments de vagues
migratoires qu'elles soient économiques
politiques climatiques
alors moi j'ai vu dans mon activité
professionnelle
arrivés par vagues ou par petit nombre
gianni mina isolés que nous accueillons
dans un établissement et qui pouvait
être protégés au titre de l'aide sociale
à l'enfance jusqu'à leur minorité
je les ai vus arriver
mineurs inconnus mineur certes en fait
qu'ils soient mineurs ou majeurs cela
m'a toujours peu importe et je les ai
vus arriver principalement d'afrique
subsaharienne
je les ai vus arriver mineurs mais
tellement adultes tellement mûri par
leur périple incroyable
je les ai vus arriver
craintif et courage ou atterré et femmes
est volontaire
je les ai vus arriver avec l'espoir fou
le pouvoir rester ici je les ai vus
arriver avec une volonté sans faille de
faire quelque chose ici tout de suite
demain
mais très vite et puis aussi avec cet
idéal
incroyable je me suis dit faut
absolument qu'on arrive à faire quelque
chose parce que si elle en majorité ils
n'ont pas leurs papiers ils seront qu'on
reste en il ya la différence mon père
qui a eu la possibilité de rentrer à
paris
après son périple après son échec
je sais qu'ils ne rentreront pas ou
certainement jamais ils ne rentreront
jamais il faut bien intégrer
parce que lauren est indissociable de
leur réalité
ils rentreront jamais parce que du pays
certains investi entre guillemets sur
leur exode et qu'ils attendent d'être
nourris dans tous les sens du terme
il attend d'être nourri par leur
présence ici alors je me suis dit c'est
une position qui a été reçu comme
politiquement incorrect me suis dit
s'ils deviennent et s'il reste ici de
toute façon autant essayer d'aménager
avec un nez clandestinité que je
qualifierais de potable quand nous avons
travaillé avec des équipes essayer de
fournir le maximum nos codes d
apprentissage sur le langage oral écrit
le plus possible et puis travailler avec
tout en raison d'employeurs
d'associations et cetera pour que ces
codes soit intégrée et que leur
clandestinité
[Musique]
j'allais dire soir viable et que si un
jour par hasard le régularisation
massive ou partielle arrivent ils
puissent en bénéficier
en tout état de cause j'essayais de
croiser ces deux destins ont ces deux
destinées finalement et vous voyez bien
que l'histoire est un éternel
recommencement et pour eux
pour ces jeunes mineurs isolés auquel je
pense certains d'ailleurs
particulièrement brillant repartir est
quasiment impossible et nous devons
méditer nous citoyens et nos politiques
doivent aussi le méditer en tant que tel
alors
au moment d'arriver un peu à la fois mon
propos je repense à mon père il écrit à
son ami et puis lui tu sais dans sa
dernière lettre je trouve charmante et
pertinente
nash du roulement de tambour qui
accompagnent les exercices périlleux de
l'équilibriste parfois il ya des moments
je me suis déjà cassé la gueule et puis
tu sais je me demande ce que je suis
venu faire ici et lui dit bas et écrire
ces lettres pas bleu est bien moins
maintenant ce que je suis venu faire ici
d'abord vous raconter une histoire
d'hommes
et puis faire le tedx merci
[Applaudissements]